now andy uh you told me that you had
something really interesting that
happened to you
uh this week and you wanted to talk
about it on the show is that correct
oh yeah conan it was awesome okay well
this is
this is great uh go ahead tell us what
happened well conan earlier this week i
was
[Music]
so then we realized it was on my head
the whole time
i'm sorry andy what was that that conan
was the
most important lesson i've ever learned
no no no i
i don't mean the story i i couldn't see
or hear anything you just said
how did you do that oh oh yeah no that's
my new paywall
your paywall yeah from now on anyone who
wants access to
premium andy richter content such as
like you know anecdotes or jokes or
or quick-witted jabs they got to pay
3.99 a month basically
what are you talking about the show
already gives you a salary how can you
have your own
paywall within the show well
you see conan
[Music]
and as it turns out i was the father
wait what uh my explanation's behind the
paywall
okay you know it's insane you've got no
shame andy
oh yeah well here's what i really think
of you you're uh
[Music]
that's not even the half of it you son
of a
but you know what the worst thing is
and then i never saw her again
andy i am ashamed of you it's just
disgusting
trying to monetize the show this way
sorry
no you're not sorry and if you don't
mind
i'd like to say something for a second
that comes from my heart
it's my father's birthday this friday
obviously i love my dad and so i want to
take just a moment of my
show to say to my father right now
[Music]
dr o'brien you know my venmo
unbelievable